Okay. I'll go ahead and
start. Just cause I'm,
I'm not sure how many people
will end up being here. So, um,
as promised today,
I will tell you a little bit about the
exam and I'll show you some questions
from a past year so that you
can see what they're like.
We rewrite the exam every year.
Um,
even makeup exams are
all different. So, um,
I have a lot of these in my files.
Um,
the exam is two and a half
hours in a three hour, um,
in a three hour slot. We have two
rooms because we have a big class.
They've given us this room and one o two.
So you can come to either room,
um, for the event. Uh, Friday, may nine,
two to five.
It has three parts.
The first part is identifications.
And that's small things from,
uh, any of the novels. That could be
a character. It could be a place name,
it could be a even a couple of words,
a quotation.
And you have to give the author and title
that it comes from of the book that it
comes from. And, um,
tell us what it is and a couple of
sentences about it's significant.
So why that thing is important.
Um,
passages will be little
chunks of text from a novel.
Again,
you'll have to know author and title,
and then you will have to do an
interpretation of the passage.
And then you have to say in a couple
of sentences how that passage as you've
interpreted it is important
to the book as a whole.
Oh, and you have to say the context of
the passage. Now, this might differ.
I'll give you a couple of examples.
This'll be different.
It might be a matter of saying
where in the plot it occurs or,
uh, who, which characters speaking, um,
what's going on in the scene
from which it's, it's pulled, uh,
some sort of relevant context so that
we know that you understand where the
thing comes from.
Um,
so you have 15 minutes
to do each of those. Um,
the essay is 40% of the,
of the final grade.
You have a half an hour,
and I'll show you,
I have a special way
of doing these essays.
Usually they're big general questions.
Um,
a good way to review for that is
to look at the old essay questions,
the essay topics.
You'll find a lot of clues there about
themes that unite all the works on the
syllabus.
So that can be a good way of studying.
In each of these sections
you will get to choose.
So in the ids usually give nine and you
get to choose six in the passages I aim
for seven and you choose for in the
essays I always give three and you choose
one.
Within the essays you can choose
to between two lists of books
to use to answer your questions.
Um, you get to choose three,
four on each of those two lists.
And I'll explain a little bit why
I do that when I show you one.
The one restriction on the essay is
that you may only write about one novel
you've written a long paper on.
So only one of the three novels that
you choose to write about for the essay
question can be one that
you wrote about in a paper.
So your TF who will be grading the
exam will know what you wrote on.
So just a observe that guideline. It's
written in the directions of the exam.
Um, now, so let me show you
now what these look like.
[inaudible]
um, first of all, I'm going to
give you a couple ideas and,
and we'll play a little game. Who
can identify this? So see horses.
Yes. No, I'm not going to call
you Sarah. That's not fair.
Only if they're all washed up.
Can anyone except Sarah identify this?
Okay. Sarah, go ahead.
How's
grandfather your grandfather?
She always wants to,
that's right. Okay. Did that seem hard
judging by the Paucity of
answers? It was, um, yes,
that's exactly what you need to say.
You need to say Maryland
Ha Robinson housekeeping.
And you'd have to explain that.
Um,
she always wanted to look at this little
drawing that her husband made for her.
Um, let me think of another
one. The dancing bear.
Yeah.
More of, you know that. Yes. I one
is it girl?
Okay. Yes, very good. So you,
that's the end of blood meridian.
You would have to say that it's at the
very end in order to get full credit for
that Id. So you need to know that.
Um, let me think of another Oh,
lane as a name.
Lean.
Yes,
yes, absolutely. And you might
want to say what he represents.
So what,
what would he represent if you were
gonna give us a sentence about what he
represents. What would you
say? Why he's important?
Kind of, uh, the editor,
the like the education,
our education system and the, um, I
forget what the exact word they use,
but the views that I'm Franny thinks
that education like that I think is
pointless. It doesn't lead
to wisdom. And he is, um,
expanding upon all these points for
being basically just gets rough.
This readings. Yes. He
doesn't actually understand.
Yes, that's true. And he's pretentious. So
he's much more interested in, in his, uh,
possibilities for publication and how
well he's done in his course than he is in
the wisdom that Franny and
Zooey both value. Okay. Yes.
So you get the idea. Um,
that's what an ideas.
So now let me show you a passage
and we'll do some of these.
Now,
the important thing
about passages is that you talk about
the language of the passage as well as
just what's in it.
So these will be chosen for the interest
of their language and you will want to
note the words and talk about why
things are said the way they're set.
Whoops, what do I need my mute. Okay,
so here's one take a moment.
Now is the time.
And folks I just couldn't in silence,
I turned Shorewood and
gravely due to flee.
She also turned and still health screen
bits council and still I could not make
myself drown. The poor,
slippery, big bodied creature.
What is this from
[inaudible]?
Yes. And what's, what is
going on in the scene?
Humbert is contemplating joining
Charlotte like hourglass.
Very good. Yes. Um,
that's all the context you would
need to identify this passage.
Now take a minute and look,
what do you think in the language of this
passage would be useful to comment on?
What do you notice about
it? But the language? Yes.
Using folks. Yes. He's
addressing, absolutely.
You would have to talk about that to get
full credit for an answer on this one.
Um, it's an address to the reader. You'd
need to talk about why he says that.
So what would your account
be for why he says that?
Because he's making tea for his innocence
and he's addressing people in informal
manner to try and sort of reach them on a,
on a friendship.
Exactly.
Yeah. And he just wants to do is
create a picture of his own mortality.
Okay. Yes. Very good. That's
a very nice way of putting it.
When you say he's making a plea
for his innocence, that, uh,
is the whole context of the novel.
That's what sets up the novel.
That's the frame of novel.
And so just by making that observation,
you've done an important thing
for the passage I notifications,
which is that you have drawn its
significance in the context of the larger
novel,
the whole novel.
What else might warrant your notice here?
What other bits of the language?
Yes.
Big bodied creature.
What about that
opposition he sets up with John's body
release his body and the body Pesto?
Absolutely. Yes. So that's, that
would be perfect. Nice and economical.
What else?
What else do you see there
that you could comment on?
Yes.
The now is the time with the
exclamation mark. Almost as like a hero.
Yes. Yeah. And what would you
make of that in an answer?
We'll do it as much as he's trying
to prove his innocence. He also, Yup.
We're really thinks of actually
getting the right thing.
Yes.
Well we're laughing about it.
You would probably want to note that
it's a comic use of that literary
convention and so you could say something
about his deployment of conventional
language,
either for satirical use or for,
for comedy or to play up the drama of his,
um, self understanding. So
that would be a nicer point.
Somewhat more subtle observation.
Um, that would set, uh,
your exam, grading, TF, uh,
into a state of happiness.
Much to be desired. All right, let me see.
Show you another one.
Okay. This one, take a minute and read it.
Right.
Okay.
What's this from?
Known world.
Okay.
Sometimes we will take
out character names. Ah,
I've done this with at a pie in the past
in crying flop 49 just because it's so,
uh, so identified with that. It seems
like too much of a dead giveaway.
I don't do that very often here.
Augustus is an easy identifier.
Um, what would you want
to say about this passage?
What do you notice about it
that seems worth accounting for?
Hmm, probably, um, with the
phrase, I know what I know.
I'm connected to the title
of the known world. Yep.
We can make a comment about how our
world is defined by what we know and the
perception of God's truth
and how that fits in.
Absolutely. Yeah. And if you,
if you could tie that notion of God's
truth to the godlike omniscience of the
narrator in the known world,
that would be a great thing to do.
And that would be way to tie your analysis
of this passage to the concerns of
the novel as a whole.
So that would be good to do.
What else do you notice
that you could make use of
thematically or formally?
Here
you lie.
It's like the barriers
to achieving the morale,
vision, morality, like, um, uh, uh,
military and ready,
kind of dream of treating slaves like,
like,
like his children and they end
up acting all his lightsaber
saying the same thing.
There should be a light that light isn't
right. So both in the, in your
example of Mildred and uh, uh,
uh, Mildred and Henry, not
Mildred, um, Henry and I'm
now I've lost her name. What is her
name? His wife's name? Oh, no. Caledonia,
um,
Henry and Caledonia have this vision of
a pure morality that they could sponsor
in their slave holding
life. And similarly, um,
this is, um, Barnum, Kinsey speaking.
You'd want to identify the speaker here,
Barnum Kinsey,
dreams of a pure space in which he
could do the morally right thing.
But as Eli was saying,
this is a novel in which no
such space or light as possible.
So you'd want to note that,
um,
that's more of a thematic element of this,
but you would want to note
that that's really important.
Anything else that we might want to say?
Yes.
Oh Wow.
In the language she repeats a body to
say in a body should stand and it's kind
of a way of preventing literary means
of decoration or like I know where it,
yeah, I think you can
definitely talk about that.
I think there are a couple of ways.
One is to associate it with literacy so
that just being as a way of testifying
somehow,
um,
that Barnum and behaving the way
he would've wanted to behave,
um,
could have done the moral thing.
But there's a contrast here between
saying it being the moral thing and his
having stood by as a body in that scene
and allowed Augustus to be sold into
slavery.
Um,
so you could certainly make hay
of that elocution and for any um,
example that uses dialect in this way,
you do want to interrogate it.
So don't just say,
well that's,
I'm just trying to sound like someone
would sound like in this social situation,
don't stop there.
That know that the passages will be chosen
so that any irregularity of language,
even if it's for the purposes
of realism in dialect,
is probably going to be
something you can talk about.
So just be aware of that and creative
in thinking about what that variation in
language could mean. Okay.
Let me show you another,
okay. What's that from? Yes,
yes. It's from on the road.
And what would you want to say about it?
Yeah.
What's important to notice about the
language and what's important in the
thematic of it?
In the content of it.
Yeah.
Yes sir.
We'll work on it.
We could talk about
like this unique sort of
speech and how I'm threatening,
which attempts to sort of like Regis
on site cause some kind of truth by I'm
getting at like intuitive understanding.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So words like that you'd need to talk
about Dean's language and just as Sarah
has done,
put it in the context of our understanding
of Dean's language and its evolution
over the course of the novel.
So that does the work of getting your
interpretation into the context of an
entire interpretation of the novel.
Um,
and there is that sense of immediacy.
So making up words and attempt
to get at a, at an, uh,
an unusual proximity to experience.
Okay.
What else would you want to notice?
Okay,
well what's he talking about?
Okay.
Yes,
yes.
Uh,
[inaudible].
Okay. Yes. Specially in what, sorry.
Yeah.
The last one we did.
Yeah, absolutely. The,
the language and the way Dean's language
falls apart over the course of the
novel is one way that he's trying to
get at a different kind of language.
But music is the figure for the,
for another way or it's another figure
for that effort to get beyond the
limitations of language.
And here the way jazz is being described,
its ability to capture
some ineffable thing.
It is what you'd want to highlight.
So you want to connect that analysis of
how jazz is being described here with
the role of jazz in the novel as a whole,
especially in the novels,
uh, linguistic ambitions.
It's literary ambitions.
Um, you might want to notice
the empty space that's,
that's, um, highlighted here.
It's another version of the vagueness of
spirituality in a couple of our novels.
On the syllabus. Um, but
certainly in on the road,
the vagueness of that thing
that they are looking for. Um,
and also you could,
you could talk about the communal dynamics
of meaning making here and you could
connect that with how it's important
that Sao and dean operate in this larger
set of people that sort of ebb
and flow throughout the novel.
This is not the individual
artists sitting alone,
but rather a dream of an American
identity that is somehow built in a free
thinking community of people or a
free acting community of people.
So you get that in all of a sudden
somewhere in the middle of the course,
he gets it,
everybody looks up and knows there's a
dream there of a shared meaning making
moment
that everyone will know it
will be immediately compelling.
Okay.
Rehashes of old blowing it.
He's talking about how jazz musicians
are in conversation with the tradition.
You could use that little piece and talk
about the way that on the road is in
conversation with other
literary traditions.
How it imagines itself as a
revision of modernism. Uh,
we had a wonderful paper that I think
some of you saw as a sample about, um,
uh,
about the relationship between
Hemingway and Kerouac in this novel.
I didn't lecture on this, but if you,
any of you saw that paper, that's a,
that's an example of what
you might want to say, uh,
about the relationship between
tradition and innovation,
which is theater based here in jazz,
but it's acted out in the novel as well.
Okay. Do you get the idea of how
these work? Okay, so this is,
this is what I'm looking for in
the passages now in the essays.
Okay.
Usually we have extremely broad questions,
some of which are more theoretical
than others. Some are more thematic,
like we had one,
I'll show you in a minute about work.
It's looks quite different
from this one. But, um,
here's the question often said that many
of the humanistic disciplines of the
second half of the 20th century or march
by their interest in language itself,
in other words, language becomes
not just a medium but a problem.
To what extent are the problems
of language foregrounded
in the novels of this
period? What are the consequences of
this turn for the writing of fiction?
How does such a foregrounding affect the
traditional terms of the novel concerns
of the novel,
the creation of character,
the relationship between style and
content, problems of various militude,
etc. Now you would have to choose one
of those groups and then within one of
those groups of novels you would need to
choose three of the four to talk about.
So the essay will be bringing together
three novels around one of these
questions.
The reason I grouped them this way is
because some of the novels on the syllabus
you could put together and have a very
partial account of fiction in this period
looks like.
So say your novels were um,
Barth pension and for all of them
have very similar formal ambitions.
Kay. I would not make it
possible for you to do that.
So I'm looking for you to be able to
take texts that seem unlike in their
concerns and in their formal elements
and put them into conversation with each
other around a particular
question. Okay. Similarly,
I would not ask you to
do, um, woman warrior,
bluest eye and known world.
Um,
I wouldn't ask you to do probably woman
warrior Blewis die and human stain
either.
Yeah.
It's all too much about identity.
In,
in somewhat similar terms.
So I wouldn't ask you those
novels together so you can
see that I mix them up.
Don't forget black boy
that will be on the exam.
If you join the course in
the middle of reading week,
I mean not in the middle
of shopping period.
You might want to go back and
fill that in to your reading.
If you haven't read that. Um, let's see.
Questions about,
about the essay questions.
Okay.
I highly, highly recommend that
you take the time to outline,
um, if you're not used to taking
essay exams or even if you are,
it is a huge help.
It's actually a time saver.
It ensures that you don't get bogged
down in sentence constructions.
When we grade these,
um,
typically what we do is make checks in
the margin every time you make a specific
point and use a specific citation
of a specific part of a novel.
So you can't quote because you don't
have the books in front of us in front of
you. Although if you do want to
use passages that are on the exam,
you can quote from those.
You can use parts of the exam
for quotation in the essay.
Um, but you do need to say, you know,
when Morrison starts each chapter of the
bluest eye with that quotation from the
primer,
she's highlighting how learning
languages also learning a kind of racial
prejudice.
And it's a kind of racial prejudice
rooted in aesthetic appreciation.
She highlights the colors that appear in
the primer and the prettiness of jeans
dresses. Okay. I didn't quote
anything from the Bluest Tie,
but I'm pointing to it in such a way that
that would have several in the column
in the margin.
And basically what we do is we rack it
up and we see whether for each novel
you've made a number of specific
points that add up to an argument.
Now in this essay, this is
the only place where, um,
we really don't want you
simply coughing up lecture
or something that you've discussed
in section. This is like the papers,
something of an opportunity to draw
things together in an original way.
There are lots of threads that
connect the novels in the syllabus.
If you've been attending the lectures,
you will already have lots of those in
your notes so you can draw from that,
but you should be thinking about it
on your own for the passages. Um,
when you start to make claims about why
the passage is important in the context
of the novel as a whole,
you may find yourself using arguments
that were made in lecture or in section
and that's fine.
So it gives you the larger context in
which you can show us that you're able to
look at the specific words on the
page and tell us something about them.
That's the skill we're testing in the
passages here. It's more your synthetic,
um, knowledge and your way
of bringing things together.
So in studying for the exam portion,
as I say,
read over the paper topics and make a
little list for yourself of kinds of
evidence that you would point to maybe
four or five bits of evidence for each
novel or for a number of novels that
might help you answer a question like that
on the exam or sit and think,
you know,
read a question and think
to your mind, okay, which,
which scenes what I note which scenes,
what I want to talk about.
That's a good exercise,
um,
for studying any questions about this?
Okay.
Let me show you one more.
So that's a very sort of,
um,
literary kind of version
of the exam question.
Let me show you something of a more,
perhaps a cultural studies version.
Here's one about work. The quotation
is from plot against America,
Philip Roth's recent novel,
which is what I taught of his last year.
So that obviously would,
would not occur on our exam.
The men worked 50 60 even
70 or more hours a week.
The women worked all the time with little
assistance from labor saving devices,
discuss the status of work in the post
1945 American novel who works and who
doesn't, how is work represented,
what kinds of work are valorized,
what kinds are vilified, what is
the place of labor in these novels,
vision of America.
So that's more thematic question.
But in all of these,
we really want you to be noting
how narratives are put together,
how language is used,
what choices the novel made in privileging
either description of character and
development of character,
development of setting
creativity in voices and tones.
So all those formal things that have to
do with language choices would still be
relevant here.
You might want to talk about the work of
the writer as that novel imagines that
we've talked about that over on and
off over the course of the term.
What is the literary project?
What does the literary project have
to do with other kinds of work?
Yeah,
so generally, uh, partly
because this course is,
is cross listed in American studies.
I like to have something of a balance
between those very literary formal
questions like that first one I showed
you and this one which is a little bit
more, a little bit more
about a vision of America.
Yeah.
Okay.
Any questions?
You probably have your,
um, probably have your
okay.
Ways of studying. Um, by now,
even freshman have been here for a year.
Um,
let me just say a couple things about
the process of studying and taking exams
that maybe will be helpful
to you. Um, my, my,
uh,
ideal way of studying for
an exam is to you sleep.
Yeah.
Do you sleep strategically?
Sleep can do amazing things for the
consolidation of knowledge in your brain.
Maybe some of you have
discovered this already. Um,
maybe some of you have
discovered it's negative.
What it does not do for
you when you do not sleep,
if you can arrange it
so that you spend time.
So you get all your reading done,
read over all your notes,
then sit down with those paper topics
and while you're sitting
with the paper topics,
that's when you move from going from
the passive mode to the active mode.
So you review all your notes,
sit down with the paper topics in that
active mode. Do what I was suggesting.
Think of scenes that pertain to those
topics for a number of the novels for each
one. Just work through that for
awhile until you can't do it anymore.
And then go to sleep right away.
Do not check your email.
Do not browse the web. Do not shoot
the breeze with your roommate.
Just go to bed.
There's a lot of research
that's been done about, um,
the effect of doing this
without distracting yourself.
You still get a benefit if you
distract yourself and then go to bed.
You still retain more of the
knowledge the next morning,
but it's even better if you do
it without distracting yourself.
Yeah.
So take it to bed with you so you can
sync right into bed, into sleep later.
Even if you can only now,
even for 20 minutes or half an hour,
it still has an effect.
So say you've only got,
you know,
you have to study for this exam during
one half of the day and then you have to
go and take another exam during
the second half of the day.
Take a nap in between.
It's probably worth the half hour.
You don't spend thinking about more
paper topics or reading your notes over
again are looking at the novels to
do that. It's probably worth it.
Okay. So that's my first tip. You
sleep strategically. My second,
uh, reflection on exam
taking is that, um, you may,
you may dismiss this out of hand given
the profession that I then took up,
but I actually used to like taking exams.
And the reason was that once you went
through that work of reading things over,
processing it after you
took the exam itself,
I always felt that the knowledge
of a course was really my own.
Then it came together in a,
in a way that was much more solid
for me then before I took the exam.
So right now the themes of the course
might just be a collection of memories or
partial memories and in your
notes and sort of chaotic.
But once you study for the exam and you
get some distance from it with sleep and
you actually write the exam,
that knowledge is really your own.
So I would encourage you to see
exam period, not just in this class,
but in all your classes as a real time,
an important time of consolidation.
You worked very hard during
the term in all your classes.
I hope and whatever you did can really
become yours in a new way during this
time. So use it well and uh, and
I hope that you'll in some way,
some part of you will enjoy that process
of, of really coming to own that,
that knowledge. Okay. Any
questions about the exam?
Okay.
Okay. Any questions about
anything in the course?
You lie.
Why do you say,
talk a little bit about
this first day,
but 1945 like particularly like what's
why post war well in America that
marks, um, two things for me.
One is the rise of the mass
market and that changes,
well actually I would say three things.
The rise of the mass market changes the
relationship between readership and the
literature that's out there. So used
to be that, um, high literature, uh,
was not published in paperback,
but the rise of the mass market paperback
men that suddenly books that would
never be accessible to a sort of average
middle class or working class person
suddenly became so,
so it's a huge watershed in
the demographics of leadership.
So that's one reason. A second
reason is related to this. Um,
and that's that
hundreds of thousands of men came back
and went to college on the Gi bill who
had never been to college before.
Nobody in their families had
ever been to college before.
This also changed the readership
dramatically. It was a time of enormous,
um, uh, an enormous boom
in college enrollments.
And part of that was a huge
boom in English enrollments.
Literature was a way for people who had
never been to college before to feel
that they were entering into the upper
middle class because it was a kind of
pursuit that was marked by its bourgeois
prestige or its prestige marked,
uh,
you as bourgeois.
So for people interested in raising
their class status and it was lots of
people, um, coming into
the educational system,
higher education for the first time
literature was very important. Um,
there's a whole story about why
literature is no longer that class marking
enterprise that it was it mid century.
Um,
that has to do with the rise of writing
the competence in writing being more
important than the competence in literary
tradition to mark you as an educated
person.
So that's an interesting story in itself.
But um,
in general,
1945 is the beginning of that.
Um,
the third thing is that by 1945,
the innovations of modernism are
really very well established.
The big careers of early century literary
enterprise are totally established and
they have been assumed almost
fully into the institution.
Of the university through
the new criticism.
The new criticism was that method
of reading literature that was,
um,
determining how people were in classrooms,
how all those new college students
were reading in classrooms, um,
that set the agenda for
what would come next.
So in that context, someone
like John Barth trained, uh,
IX intensively in the new criticism had
to decide what he was going to do as
literarily ambitious writer to innovate.
So it was a question of how could
literature carry on and do something new.
And there are lots of different answers
to that. And another answer to it. Um,
that is partly the result of the
Gi bill explosion of education.
That's the changing demographic of who
gets to read and who gets to write. Um,
so women,
people of color began to
change the agendas of modernism
simply by getting that
education and entering into the academy.
So Toni Morrison is a great example of
that. Um, so as Maxine Hong Kingston,
there was this sense that modernism
had not even begun to touch on the
experience of vast swathes of society
and writers like Morrison and,
and Kingston.
We're very busy wanting to rectify that.
So it marks a change that's beyond
just a change in readership.
The demographic change in readership
and an education really begins to change
the agenda of literature. So
that's why 45 is my, my marker.
It's a crude while I'm like all these
things, you know, you can't say, well,
why not? 1942, you know,
it doesn't quite work.
Work that specifically.
Okay. Other questions?
Well,
the course about terms about books,
yes. Of the novels. We read one of your,
you do, do you? Hmm.
Gosh, that's really, really hard.
Um, I do love the known world.
I really admire it.
Um,
I think it's genuinely doing something
new and that's hard to do right now.
Um, so I love it and I loved
it as a reading experience.
Even when I first read it, it
really captured my imagination. Um,
I've always loved and
hated blood Meridian.
I love and hate Cormac McCarthy. I've
spent a lot of time thinking about him,
writing about him,
reading his work.
And while I'm really,
uh,
in awe of his ability,
especially to use the far reaches
of our vocabulary in English,
I mean, talk about someone who
really makes room in the language.
Um, he can really do that. If you
read the first few pages of a,
of one of his, um,
earlier novels, such tree,
you get a fantastic image of this.
It's a very Joycey and novel
that won the vocabulary.
You just have to look up
like every third word.
It's really incredible and I'm really
interested in the way he is focused on
craft, both as a writer but
all kinds of crafts, crafts.
Like he has this play called
the last stone mason. Uh,
I think it's called the last last
John Mason. We're just the Stonemason,
the stonemason.
Um,
he's interested in these old arts
like physical arts, like forging.
There's a great chapter on, um, on, uh,
smithing in a novel called the Child of
God where the language of of the Smithy
is folded into this.
Um,
meditation on aesthetics talks about what
color the fire and the metal should be
at every moment of reforging an ax handle.
Of course in true McCarthy's style,
the ax handle will then be used
to chop up dead bodies and,
and skin people. Uh, so
that's very McCarthy ask too,
but at the same time I just find
him frustratingly empty. Um,
the road I adored,
it was a terrifying read.
I had insomnia one night and I started
to read it at about one 30 in the morning
and I finished it about five 30
and I was terrified. Um, it's,
have I told you about the road
when it's about, it takes,
it takes place 10 years into a nuclear
winter and it's about a father and son
making their way down from Appalachia
to the Gulf coast for no apparent reason
except that the father seems to think
that somehow there'll be able to survive
better once they get to the coast.
Um,
meanwhile in this world,
there are all these cannibalistic
gangs that have started.
A women are used to produce
babies that they then eat a,
it's really completely
bleak and terrifying.
And that the relationship between the
father and the son is extremely touching,
you know, and I have a little boy who
is about the same age and Oh my God,
I was just doing, it was really
terrifying to read this, uh,
all alone in the middle of the night,
I sort of got in bed with my son later.
It is kind of cuddled with him, um,
to remember that he was still alive.
But,
um,
at the end there's this sense
of the boy carrying the light.
They, you know, the father says, you
know, we're carrying the light. Um,
we're the good guys. And the sun
sort of repeats that by the end.
I won't tell you what happens
cause you should read it, but, um,
there's this affirmation of that light,
but what the light is, who knows?
There's sort of a
promethian narrative there.
There's also a messianic narrative
there. Um, I think personally,
my own reading of it is that it's
McCarthy meditating on the end of his own
life. Mccarthy is a very old
man with a very young son,
and I think he was thinking
about his own death. And, uh,
the fate of the father in that novel
I think is very much about McCarthy,
his sense of himself. So
yeah, McCarthy is a tough one.
Um, in Marilyn Robinson,
I like a lot. Also,
I like the beauty of her prose. Um,
that Biblical cadence that Sheen,
Mccarthy both have. I really
like, I love the outdoor imagery,
the nature imagery of that novel.
And I love Roth for my own
obscure and perverse reasons.
Um, yeah, so
I sort of have my favorites,
but I like them. I really,
there are things that I like
about all of them. You know,
interesting story about liking novels.
I hated Salinger.
I really hated Salinger,
um,
because I found him so
pretentious and effected.
I just hated that tone of voice until
I was working on this book on religion.
And I read Franny and Zooey and here
you can tell most of my great thought
happens in the middle of the night.
So I had been thinking about Franny
and Zooey and I suddenly woke up in the
middle of the night thinking,
I know what style is for in the middle of,
in Franny. And Zooey so I got
up and I wrote it down. And um,
that lecture that I gave on Franny and
Zooey is part of my new book. And when,
when the book was reviewed,
uh, for presses, um,
a part of it, I, one of my
readers said it was the,
it was the best reading he'd ever
seen of contemporary fiction.
And it made me love Franny and Zooey
because suddenly I had suddenly I had
something to think about other than like,
this is so pretentious.
I had a reason why, uh, why that,
that tone in that style was there.
So you know, thinking about
books can really change your,
your sense of whether you like
them or not. It is self, sir.
I know in a self serving way
now who's pretentious? Um,
okay.
Other questions?
Oh yes.
Conversation with their roommate yesterday
and we really like the bluest eye and
there's one way we didn't read
the loved one the more I said,
well maybe because a lot of them,
so Brian,
a little bit American Asian
American literature. Yes.
[inaudible] just kind of buckled his
academic snobbery to not to move below it.
You must read the last grade,
don't or not popular?
Oh, no, not at all.
I used to teach beloved and I stopped
because of that because we put it on the
one 27 syllabus partly,
and that wasn't here when
I first started teaching.
So the first time I offered this
lecture course, one 27 didn't,
and then we put it in
place in the department.
And because it was on that syllabus,
I held off.
I still think beloved is an amazing novel.
I also have the length problem
in that part of the period.
I'm sure you didn't notice that,
um,
that the novels are along and
that part of the syllabus,
a beloved is another really huge
novel so that it's, it's a problem.
So I decided instead of putting it on
there to rely on the fact that most people
would either have read it in high school,
or at least a majority would have
read it in high school or in one 27.
And that I could count on that knowledge
at least in a contextual sense.
But no, it has nothing to do with
academic snobbery. Now. I was,
I used to get pissed off
because when it was on the, um,
when it was on the syllabus,
I would always get certain
evaluations would come in and say, oh,
I don't know why we read beloved. It's
such a, it's so overrated. You know,
that was the snobbery and I that made
me upset because I thought, well,
that's just a failure of openness as a,
as a reader,
not to think about why it was so powerful.
Even if you don't like it yourself,
but your answer was right.
It's, it's simply because
it's taught a lot elsewhere.
And then those other
practical reasons of length.
What else?
Oh, well, I'm sure.
Yeah. Um, so let's see.
What else would I put on there? Um, well,
let me think.
Louise Erdrich is interesting to me.
There's a long novel of hers called,
um, the last report on the miracles.
A little no horse, which I think is an
imaginative concede is really fascinating.
It's this, the premise of the novel
is that this young woman who, uh,
is a, is a wonderfully
gifted pianist who, uh,
goes,
I can't remember where she's heading.
It's been now a long time
since I read the novel.
She's traveling and she
gets washed away in a flood,
a freak flood of a river.
This is out west.
And when she finally surfaces,
she crawls up on the bank and she finds,
uh,
the body of a young priest
who is on his way to be, uh,
the priest at a mission on a reservation,
on an Indian reservation, uh,
I think in the,
in the Dakotas.
So she cuts off her hair and she puts on
the priest's robes and she pretends to
be that priest and she becomes,
she crossed dresses and is the priest
at the reservation for her entire life.
And I just think it's a fascinating
premise, uh, for a novel.
And it's very well done in her
language is quite, um, quite wonderful.
I again, uh, I'm ambivalent about
it because I find the ending facile,
um,
it finally resolves all the problems that
this situation produces in a way that
I don't find a complex
enough or challenging enough.
It's just too easy to let it make it
all come together the way she does. Um,
so that's one. Um, let me think.
There are like many,
many other novels I can perpetually
torn whether to put the road on. Yeah.
We're blood meridian or
some other McCarthy novel.
I've taught at least four different,
um,
Roth novels spanning the
period from 1962 the present.
Um, other writers now, I don't
know why I'm blanking now that I,
um, that I think about this. Um,
hmm. Who else did I like to put
on there? Oh, Eggers I really,
now I fess up. I really would
have loved to do what is the,
what as our last novel.
Um,
I think Eggers now Edgar started out
immature in the same way that I think
Jonathan Safran Foer is,
but he grew up as a beautiful thing.
Um,
so heartbreaking work of
staggering genius, has a lot
of that sort of, you know,
kind of Cliche postmodern trickery in it.
Um,
but by the time it gets to what is the,
what that novel is like nothing else,
there is no equivalent of that novel to
my knowledge anywhere in our tradition.
Uh, it's just an astonishing
inhabitation of another person's life.
But in real time, I mean, I, I had,
I was able to have dinner with him and
some other people when he came as the
slessinger writer a few years
ago, and I said, you know,
did you find it confining to give
yourself over in that creative way to this
other person's story? He said, yeah, it
was terrible. I would want to, you know,
I'd be writing the truck
went down the road,
he'd have to call Valentino and say,
um,
Valentino,
that truck was the road gravel
or was it paved and was it dusty?
Was there stuff kicking up or,
or was it just flat? You know,
it was just amazing.
The,
the degree to which he put his writing
pen at the service of another person and
their story.
It's really remarkable.
So given that extremely confining set up,
he makes that novel truly literary
in my mind. It has a real form.
It has a very lively voice, um,
and it's extremely powerful,
fall and effecting.
So that's something I would,
I would love to have. But
again, it's a huge novel. This
is, the problem is so long.
I, I think I just need two semesters.
I think that would be better. Yes.
I haven't read it yet, but I have to
say the reviews that I hear about it.
So what is it exceeding loud? Incredibly
close, exceedingly, incredibly,
extremely, uh, extremely loud
and incredibly close. Um,
the structure of the plot makes me doubt
a little bit because it's just another
hunt.
So it's this nine year old boy who loses
his father on nine 11 and he finds in
his father's affects a
key that's marked black,
I think has a little label on it.
And so he goes around New York City
finding everyone by the name of black that
he can find.
Um,
so it has the structure that's so
similar to everything is illuminated.
That hunt structured just made me
think, hmm. I wonder whether this is,
I mean,
is this just a one trick writer that
he has this idea and this is what it's
always going to be.
A,
that doesn't necessarily mean that
someone is not a great writer. You know,
Roth has kind of a one trick
pony in this way too. Um,
he has his own repetitions
from novel to novel.
Most writers I know do,
but that seemed a little too,
it's a little too close for me, so I don't
know. I have to find time to read it.
Dennis Johnson,
I did actually,
I was very interested in having
Jesus son as the last novel to,
I'm going to write a review for the
overview on Denis Johnson's, um,
work by the end of July.
So by then I'll know what
I think about him too.
Hmm.
Other questions or shall I let you go?
Any other questions?
Okay. So I will see you at
the exam and I think some,
some sections are having review sessions.
So check with your TF.